now unfortunately tonight biden harris
continue to embarrass the whole country
on the world stage projecting weakness
doubling down on their failed far left
policies and as usual a never-ending
stream of bizarre blunders by both of
them now here's the vice president
yesterday with the president of poland
watch this embarrassment is the united
states willing to make a specific
allocation for ukrainian refugees
and for president duda i wanted to know
if you think and if you asked the united
states to specifically accept more
refugees
okay
a friend in need is a friend indeed
okay so this time
giggling is the perfect way to answer a
serious question about uh refugees that
moment was so bad that even the
ukrainian president zielinski's former
press secretary tweeted it would be a
tragedy if harris ever became president
that's probably an understatement now of
course creepy bizarre giggling is
nothing new for the vice president let's
take you down a short trip of memory
lane here you might recall some of this
do you plan to visit the border
not today
more parents are seeing the value of
educators when they had to bring their
kids
and say we're not paying them nearly
enough
because there's an interesting fact in
case you didn't know
hard hats are actually unisex
everybody's laughing you're considered
the most liberal united states senator
i
somebody said that and it actually was
mike pence on the debate stage but yeah
lots of giggles anyway according to the
media mob and the co-hosts of that
hard-hitting news show the view on abc
if you think laughing off questions
about really serious issues is
unprofessional that means you are racist
and you are a sexist take a look
did you have a problem with any of the
way she handled this uh ladies uh people
are talking about about it that i
personally think if she was a guy they
would never say it because they also
made fun of hillary's laugh what it is
is that they constantly question the
qualifications of black women and that's
why people are saying that she's
unprepared oh i disagree i think you can
disagree but that's the truth of it and
so this is based in racism this is based
in misogyny absolutely there's a racial
aspect too all right
here with reaction co-host to the five
judge jeannie imperials with us along
with fox news contributor joe concha
judge you know i don't know i say about
the president that he's weak and frail
and he's obviously a cognitive mess and
then we got a vice president that gets
serious questions
and giggles i don't know what's worse
you decide
well i got to tell you if anything the
one purpose she serves is as an
insurance policy to make sure that joe
biden stays there the idea that a woman
the highest ranking woman in the united
states goes to uh
to poland to stand with the president of
poland is not prepared for a question as
to whether or not the united states is
willing to help refugees that she looks
to the president of another country that
she's there to uh to to to reassure and
then starts giggling like a fool is an
absolute embarrassment and i am sick and
tired of people saying it's about color
let me tell you something when it came
to connie rice nobody questioned her
confidence when it came when it comes to
the woman right now
the candidate or the nominee for supreme
court katanji brown jackson there is no
one questioning her qualifications this
woman should be questioned she makes an
embarrassment of herself whenever she
gets on the world stage and by the way
doesn't she know about refugees i mean
isn't she the borders are and this is a
continuing continuing uh image that we
see of her and she should not be allowed
out of the united states if she's going
to be an embarrassment to this country
joe koncha we we have images now of a
mass grave we have images of a maternity
hospital that was attacked dozens of
schools have been hit entire
neighborhoods have been blown up uh
we've got a refugee crisis two two and a
half million people that's what she was
asked
how do you explain that response of hers
i don't get it
this is not a serious person in a very
serious time sean and as far as blaming
racism i go back to an interview kamala
harris did after she dropped out of the
democratic primaries before one vote was
cast right and she blamed sexism and
racism for her support being so low
which is a very odd way to talk about
democratic voters so this is the
playbook here by the candidate and by
the vice president and by her super pac
that is the view play the gender in the
race card from the bottom of the deck
but the deep's problems come down to
very basic things voters see her as
ill-equipped for the job that's based on
odd statements like you know it's time
for us to do what we have been doing in
that time is every day i literally
have that quote hanging uh here in my
home studio it's right next to reagan's
mr gorbachev tear down this wall and uh
this one pain heels chick stick scars
glory lasts forever that one's from
keanu reeves and we can talk about that
another time but in the end miss harris
has a communication problem she has an
authenticity problem she has a
likability problem and more importantly
she is failing on performance this
critique has to to the judge's point has
nothing to do with race or gender
because i would say the same thing about
the old white guy that happens to be her
boss on the same issue more than 2
million people have crossed into this
country over the u.s southern border in
in the last year alone that's triple the
size of the total population of boston
and despite comparing ice to the kkk she
was put in charge of fixing it and it's
only getting worse as she plays the role
of absentee landlord and now we see her
cackling again to your point when asked
a basic question in poland yesterday
with the world watching in the end she
was supposed to be playing beta biden
now she's plan z even among many
democrats sean thank you judge thank you
joe concha hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else